welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer networks
what is a protocol today we're going to
be focusing on protocols
and we're going to take a detailed look
at the protocols underlying the internet
and it turns out that
the protocols governing the internet
have quite a bit to do
with what we can or can't do with the
internet and why the internet acts the
way it does
so let's start off by answering the
question what in the world is a protocol
i want to start off by
talking about why we need protocols and
i think that will give you a better
sense of
what the protocols actually are all
right
let's go back to the example we had last
lecture where
i've got a bunch of computers on the
wi-fi network in a classroom and i'm
trying to send a message to my friend
at the end of last lecture we talked
about naming schemes and how to identify
individual computers on the network so
at this point
we have a way of identifying each
individual computer
so suppose i want to send this message i
don't have to send it to everybody in
classroom now i can give the specific
address for my friend's computer and
make sure it goes to her
but what am i actually sending
am i just sending the message and she's
just gonna get a random message saying
somebody sent her the i love computer
science
are we gonna identify it with the
address of the computer
this kind of seems a little bit creepier
if we're using
the physical or mac address here might
be a little bit better if i had the host
name although
although in general most computers don't
actually have host names host names are
generally
reserved for things like web servers
where a lot of people are going to have
to access it using a name
what i might want to do is include some
sort of information with the message
that identifies who sent the message
and who that message is going to so
maybe something like this to tammy from
patrick
but i have to decide exactly how that's
being sent
remember what's really being sent from
one computer to the other is just a
sequence of bits
organizing to byte so you know maybe i
put her name first
followed by a that's the ascii null that
slash zero is the ascii null
uh which corresponds to the entire
byte being just zeroed out followed by
my name
or i could send my name followed by the
ask you know followed by her name
or i could tack on a from
and a two and then the question comes
well is the from followed by colon
is it followed by dash the basic idea
here is
there's lots of different ways this
message can get sent but what needs to
occur
is both my computer and her computer
need to be in complete agreement
on exactly what this message looks like
not just the contents of the message
but the other information associated
with the message like what format am i
going to use to send
who the sender is and who the recipient
is
and so this is really what a protocol is
a protocol is an agreement between two
or more computers
on how they plan to carry out a task
let's take a look at a real-life
protocol we're going to look at the http
protocol this is the protocol used by
the worldwide web
and as you can see here http stands for
hypertext transfer protocol
we'll actually be talking about exactly
what hypertext is
next lecture
for now here's my laptop it's
connected to the internet you remember
these diagrams from
last lecture representing some sort of a
network and
i'm connected to part of the network and
then there's a whole bunch of other
networks
between my network and where the web
server is and that's the
dot dot the internet and as you recall
from last lecture the internet is
actually
an internet work a connection of
a whole bunch of different networks all
combined together
and then on the far side we've got the
web server now
i'm representing the web server by just
a box please don't tell my art teachers
i've completely given up on any sort of
perspective drawing
but here on this inset here you can
actually see what a web server actually
looks like and what we're seeing here is
this is a rack that has a whole bunch of
different computers in it
each of the horizontal components inside
this rack actually represents a
different computer
and this is what most of the web
computers that you're interacting with
look like particularly if you're
interacting with a commercial
installation
but we're just going to represent it by
that square box okay so here's the
simplified diagram i'm getting rid of
all the internet stuff but do keep in
mind that internet
is still there okay so i've got my
computer
and i need to contact the web server we
saw previously that
the web server is identified by the host
name
and that needs to get converted to an ip
address
also known as ipnumber and then i'm
going to go ahead and send the request
through the internet to the web server
now it turns out that there's actually
several types of requests i can make to
a web server
i can make a get request which says hey
you have some information can you go
ahead and send it to me
i can use a put request which says hey
i want you to do something for me that's
going to modify your state
here's some information you might need
and this is used for things like
say electronic commerce where i'm
actually putting an order
so i'm sending the order information to
the server and the server is
changing its status so that it remembers
my order
there's a delete which generally you're
only going to be able to do if you have
authorization
anyway the point is here there's a whole
bunch of different requests there are
several more that i have not covering
here
so this only needs to be part of the
http protocol
when a a laptop or some other computer
is connecting to
the web server what sort of requests can
it make of that web server
and in addition to the request type such
as get or post or delete
there's actually a bunch of other
information that gets attached to the
request
and so these are just a couple examples
we talked about character encodings in
fact we talked about character encodings
the very first day of class
when you learned how to store egyptian
hieroglyphs you've seen
the unicode utf-8 character encoding so
i can send
information to the web server saying
these are the sorts of character
encodings i can handle
you can send a request to the server
saying hey
i have a copy of this file but if the
file on the server has been
modified since a particular date then i
want a new copy of it
you can tell it that you accept
particular types of encoding and in this
case i'm not talking about
character encoding i'm actually talking
about the compression technique so
we've talked about compression with
images we talked about compression with
sounds compression also occurs with
files
you guys have experimented with that if
you've ever used a zip file
and so one thing that the server can do
is it can
zip up the files together or use some
other compression technique to reduce
the amount of space those files take
before sending them through the
worldwide web and so that's what the
accept encoding is saying it's saying
hey i can handle those zip files if you
want to go ahead and send them to me in
that format
and so you can see that there's lots of
different options that
the sender or the requester can do with
this particular protocol
and then as far as the response goes the
main part of the response is the files
that i'm going to get back in this case
i'm representing as an html file we'll
talk about html again next week
but in addition there's other things
that
the web server can send to the
requester that includes
hey this content is encoded here's the
encoding
it includes here's how long this file is
good for here's when it's gonna expire
and then typically it will also include
an idea of how long the file is so that
the
recipient will know when the file is
done transferring
another important part of the protocol
is the status code
you may be familiar with some of these
the 200 code you guys never see
but your computer does receive it when
your computer receives a 200 code it
knows oh everything's good
and then of course we have the infamous
404 which means
you're requesting a file but that file
does not exist
the 403 which in some respects i think
is a little bit harsher which says
yeah that file's there but i'm not
giving it to you
you don't have permission and then 500
which means there's a server error in
fact there's a
whole slew of these different status
codes and so
this is just a simple introduction to
http
but mostly i wanted to give you a sense
of what a protocol looks like using a
real-life
protocol and so from this we can see
that yes a protocol
is an agreement between two or more
computers on how they're going to carry
out a task on the network
but we also see that sorts of
information that needs to be included
so the protocol should specify what
sorts of requests
one computer can make of another request
what sort of information
would be sent with that what the format
of that information is
and then also important is what to do
when something goes wrong and that's why
we have those different error codes we
saw there
one topic students often find confusing
is what is the relationship between a
protocol and a program
so let's take a quick look at that we've
seen how the http protocol works
there are many different programs that
support the http protocol
so for example chrome firefox
safari edge these are all programs that
run
on our personal computers that
understand
how to communicate with web servers
using the http protocol
and as long as our web browser programs
understand and follow the same rules
they can interoperate with any of the
web
servers similarly there are many
different
types of web servers out there and as
long as the programs on those web
servers follow the rules for http
they are able to respond to requests
from the different web browsers
i should also mention that while most of
us typically think of the program that
is making requests to the web
server as our traditional web browser
there are other programs out there that
make the exact same http request to the
web server as our
traditional web browsers do so just to
provide a few examples
there are audio web browsers which
people that are visually impaired use
and they will actually be able to read
the web page to somebody
and then there are other programs such
as the google search bot which
doesn't even involve a human being it
just makes requests to web pages
and uses those web pages to build up its
database which it can use to
tell us how to find particular topics
the bottom line is the protocol just
specifies
a set of rules that different programs
need to follow
if they want to interact with the other
computers
on the network that are planning to work
together to carry out this task
many people can write different programs
following those protocols
and in fact as we've seen here with http
they often do
in the next series of videos we're going
to take a look at the actual protocols
on the internet
it turns out that the protocols on the
internet are what it's referred to as
layered this is a relatively complex
topic but by
understanding the layered protocols
and how they work you will have a much
much stronger understanding of how the
internet works so
we're going to go ahead and go over this
the next video is going to talk about
what layered protocols actually are and
then
after that we'll take a closer look at
the actual layers used on the internet
i'll talk to you soon
you